in dieser Woche trainieren Österreichs
Biathlon Spitzensportler auf ungewohntem
Terrain auf dem Übungsgelände der
Eliteeinheit des Bundesheeres schießen
David komath Simon Eder Lisa Hauser und
Co unter Anleitung von Spezialisten des
Jagdhorns bin eigentlich ja sehr
gespannt in die Woche gegangen ich habe
nicht wisst genau was mir erwartet aber
das Schießtraining war sehr positiv und
hat das Augentraining was mir immer
vorab eigentlich gemacht haben hat schon
sehr viel Positives Aspekte und ich
glaube die kann man bei uns bei
immobilienübungen mit dem STG also dem
Sturmgewehr des Bundesheeres sind für
manche Sportler eine neue Erfahrung
objagdkommando Soldaten mit dem kleinen
kalibrigen Biathlon Gewehr ebenso viel
Erfolg haben können ich glaube das ist
geplant also dass man sie noch schützen
Wiedersehen und sehr gerne
offen her oder stellst zur Verfügung und
dann kommen sie mit kleineren Geräten
gemessen und da ist natürlich ein
bisschen die Ziele okay und wir machen
okay
Übungen haben die 12 Sportlerinnen und
Sportler auch Einblicke in so manche
Gepflogenheiten beim Jagdkommando
bekommen es ist auf jeden Fall schon
cool wenn er wenn er Austausch
stattfindet ich glaube das ist für beide
Seiten gutes sehr wertvoll sein was
dieses Spezialtraining für die nächste
Biathlon Saison unseren österreichischen
Spitzensportlern gebracht hat wird sich
zeigen eine ist jetzt schon vom großen
Erfolg überzeugt die
Verteidigungsministerin überzeugt davon
die sind sowieso sensationell wir haben
bei der Weltmeister dabei also das wird
in jedem Fall so besonderen sportlichen
Leistungen führen